bonjour henry olivier michaud bonjour
vous êtes responsable événementiel d'une
des manifestations au sermac c'est bien
ça arrive exactement
demain débute le 46e festival culturel
de fort de france qui a pour thème cette
année la culture est essentielle vous
parlez de quoi exactement de quelle
culture mais on parle de notre culture
la culture martiniquaise une culture qui
est riche et une culture que le seo maka
a pour mission de transmettre et de
diffuser le maximum depuis déjà presque
50 ans donc on est toujours dans une
démarche de transmission de partage de
cette culture et d'accessibilité pour
tous à cette culture martiniquaise qui
est la nôtre
est ce qu'aujourd'hui à l'heure où le
monde est secoué par dix attentats on
parle parfois aussi de repli sur soi
est-ce que plus que la politique la
culture ne doit pas être de ne doit pas
prendre le pas être avec doit pas
construire une société
évidemment la structure la culture je
pense et c'est ce qu'il va c'est ce qui
pourra rassembler tout le monde sait ce
qui fait d'eux un peuple c'est ce qui
caractérise une population sans culture
où il n'ya pas de peuple il n'y a pas
d'identité et la culture est
certainement l'élément qui pourra
fédérer les martiniquais fédérer les
festivaliers et permettre à tout le
monde de pouvoir se retrouver sur un
socle commun et sans aucune animosité ou
ça devrait fédérer aussi les politiques
évidemment que ça devrait fédérer les
politiques ça devrait être quelque chose
où il n'y a pas de débat où on dépose
les armes si vous voulez où tout le
monde devrait tomber d'accord
quelle que soit son opinion politique ou
son clivages bon après
il ya toujours des petites
particularités entre municipalités
collectivités et cetera mais ça devrait
être quelque chose qui fédère et qui
permet à tout le monde de se rassembler
un outil pour mieux vivre ensemble
exactement alors l'ouverture du festival
se fera par fall fret samedi un groupe
habitué
vous avez de tabler sur une valeur sûre
oui valeo suez puis fall fritz est l'un
des premiers groupes martinique et de
musiques traditionnelles alternative
donc ils semblaient pour nous presque
évident cette année de pouvoir les
mettre en ouverture de ce festival
habituer parce que oui et non il ce sont
des jacuzzis effectivement festival
c'est la première année qu'il feront
l'ouverture c'est une vallée aussi au
goût qu'on ne présente plus connue
reconnue donc effectivement ça semblait
pour nous une excellente idée alors et
ensuite dimanche loi le carnaval d'izard
la parade dans les rues via un thème il
ya des nouveautés pour cette parade on
essaie la septième édition je crois
c'est ça oui exactement alors un thème
pas exactement le cas en avant dix ans
c'est l'événement familial par
excellence du festival c'est ce qu'il
lance dans les oui le festival de
fort-de-france avec bien sûr une
structure qui ne change pas avec un
village des enfants avec des groupes à
pied parce que l'idée de cette
manifestation c'était de permettre aux
personnes qui ne vivent pas en
martinique pendant l'année qui compte
pendant les vacances
davant un petit goût de carnaval pendant
les grandes vacances puisqu'ils ne
peuvent pas en profiter
au mois de février donc bien sûr des
nouveautés dans ce qu'on va proposer sur
les parades lumineuse
on aura du mapping sur certains
immeubles du circuit autour de la savane
n'a péri pour ceux qui ne connaissent
pas c'est de la projection vidéo donc à
suivre sur certains immeubles donc des
petites surprises qu'on l'est qu'on
laisse découvrir comme on a pu voir une
grande ville lui on toulouse est
exactement midi
une troupe une troupe de métropole qui
viendrait avec des girafes ont pas
diriger la fois digigraphie géante qui
vont déambuler avec des jeux de lumière
de la fugue n'était pas franchement je
donne rendez vous aux gens dimanche sa
partie de keller c'est à partir de 14
heures
et puis tout ce qui est des angulation
commence en fin d'après midi début de
soirée le festival se passe également
dans les quartiers plusieurs
représentations
mais ce que vous avez quantifier
l'impact de ce festival dans les
quartiers oui on le quantifie tout au
long de l'année parce que les gens sont
demandés dans les quartiers viennent
vers nous nous nous demander à ce que
les cartes chez soi dynamiser site une
volonté aussi de la municipalité du may
ans que le festival ne soit pas
cloisonnés dans les rues du centre-ville
et que le festival porte à la rencontre
des personnes qui ne peuvent pas
forcément quitter le quartier
on a des centres culturels dans des
quartiers qui pendant toute l'année
participent à la dynamisation du karoshi
donc on leur propose des pièces de
théâtre des concerts de gospel dans les
églises qui aura par exemple à l'église
de vos doutes des pièces de théâtre
sainte thérèse à l'ermitage donc oui oui
c'est c'est une partie du festival qui
non négligeable et qui est très demandée
attendu par les festivaliers nouveauté
festival à l'hôpital vous avez décidé
d'investir deux hôpitaux si ça
n'explique qu'une alors on a décidé
d'investir un hôpital celui de mango
ville sainte de partis encore une fois à
la rencontre de ceux qui ne peuvent pas
se déplacer
donc il y aura des comptes qui seront
qui seront proposés aux patients de
l'hôpital de mon beau fils c'est et pour
les plus jeunes pour les enfants en
situation de handicap aussi également
nous irons aux fougères pour pouvoir
leur proposer sur le même type
d'activité toujours dans une dynamique
de de permettre à tout le monde d'avoir
accès à la culture d'avoir accès aux
animations du festival même ceux qui
n'ont qui ont du mal à se déplacer conte
interactif les patients pourront
participer exactement des comptes et
actifs et puis un échange aussi avec les
artistes et les comédiens qui
à l'ime les fougères mais aussi à
l'hôpital de mangot vulcin est ce qu'on
peut imaginer un jour le festival de
fort-de-france sortir de ses murs des
murs foyalais se décentraliser un
partenariat avec d'autres communes afin
de proposer par exemple des pièces
je sais pas cette mari à sainte anne au
marais
ou bien dans le nord caraïbe au carbet à
au prêcheur par exemple donc
personnellement c'est quelque chose qui
je me plairait je pense qu'il pleuvait à
tous les martiniquais en général ce
serait peut-être plus le festival de
fort-de-france à ce moment là parce que
peut-être le festival de la martinique
mais je pense qu'ils le festival de
fort-de-france c'est une institution
c'est quelque chose qui a été écrit par
aimé césaire c'est quelque chose qui à
50 ans c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
maintenir maintenant lui permettre
d'évoluer ou bien proposer quelque chose
qui pourrait aller au-delà du niveau de
fort de france qui pourrait permettre à
tous les martiniquais de se retrouver
autour d'un socle commun festival
pluridisciplinaire
je pense que c'est quelque chose qu'il
faut causer qu'il faut travailler que
c'est quelque chose qui pourrait voir le
jour dans les années futures
ça pourrait donner aussi vie à plusieurs
vies aux pièces par exemple une vie une
représentation à fort de france
et puis une représentation aux communes
est comme ça les élisent les acteurs les
comédiens pourraient
c'est se produire les premiers gagnants
de d'une évolution comme celle ci savait
les comédiens qui trouverait davantage
de représentation et davantage
d'opportunités de proposer lo lo
création et de de montrer ce qu'ils
savent faire mais comme je vous dis
c'est quelque chose qui doit se
travailler qui doit se préparer je pense
que la volonté y est je pense que la
nouvelle génération que peut-être je
représente c'est quelque chose qu'on a
en réflexion et c'est quelque chose
qu'on aimerait peut-être développer dans
le futur sans pour cela bouscule est
certes une certaine identité comme le
festival de fort de france qui est quand
même quelque chose de particulier de
l'incontournable le temps fort c'est le
cirque du vietnam c'est ça alors alors
que sir particulier ceux ci avec des
comédiens des acrobates
c'est un spectacle assez assez
exceptionnel je veux vraiment invité les
gens à cyron et ainsi où tout ne pas
perdre de temps parce qu'on reçoit
énormément d'appels pour ce spectacle
dont la billetterie ouvre sa vie donc je
vais inviter les gens à aller au plus
vite prendre l'antique et parce que je
pense que les quatre représentations
seront à guichet fermé je pense que les
martiniquais ont peu d'occasions un jour
de voir ce spectacle ou de salifou nous
le proposons c'est à dire un tarif de 30
euros
ce sont des spectacles qui se joue à des
tarifs qui peuvent avoisiner les 70 80
ou non certaines salles en france donc
profitez-en c'est un spectacle qui en
mettra plein la vue ce sont ces une
troupe venue tout droit du vietnam qu'on
a fait venir juste pour pour le festival
donc on a parlé je vous ai parlé
d'argent nous festival coûte combien
cette année
or le budget du festival il va lui a à
peu près un million deux cent mille
euros si en augmentation par rapport aux
on se maintient sur les années
précédentes avec une légère baisse mais
vraiment pas significative mais on est à
peu près sur le même budget que les
dernières années il nous reste très peu
de temps
la jazz nights est quand même festival
dans le festival quand on regarde la
programmation c'est à dire
juif c'est l'un des événements phares du
festival de fort-de-france avec cette
année une pointure était en national en
la personne de stan lee clark jr fois
nominé loué à deux grammy awards donc
festival dans le festival je ne sais pas
mais incontournable du festival sans
aucun doute et puis à la clôture avec la
caribbean night we live in hyde dans les
jardins du parc culturel aimé césaire
avec diva nul par exemple ce sera un
rassemblement de plusieurs groupes
d'artistes qui nous proposons un concert
autour de musiques caribéennes germain
également géré mais également donc aussi
une clôture en boutis pour son 46e
festival
voilà on a fait un peu le tour henri
olivier michaud juste une petite
précision cette année petite nouveauté
enfin grande nouveauté l'application du
festival qui vous permet de vous
mark von de télécharger cette appli
festival de fort-de-france où vous aurez
toutes les informations le programme et
descriptions des manifestations donc
n'hésitez pas voilà donc henry olivier
michaud je vous remercie mais il ya une
bonne journée sur notre antenne
[Musique]